everybody was just kind of floored
through the whole thing and yeah um
yeah and i was just thinking like about
how am i gonna what am i gonna do
amy schumer is giving a little more
insight into the tense moments that
followed will smith slapping chris rock
at the 2022 oscars
the 40 year old comedian co-hosted the
big night alongside regina hall and
wanda sykes getting to do this with
regina and wanda they are such heroes of
mine they are comedy royalty we've been
having so much fun i've enjoyed every
second of getting ready with these
ladies fast forward a week and a half
later and the life and beth star stopped
by watch what happens live with andy
cohen amy shares her two cents about
will receiving a standing ovation for
his best actor win just minutes after
the shocking slap
i was backstage and
and i knew i had to go out i was kind of
the only host that was going out solo
after that so it really felt like the
situation room
you know like of comedy like we were all
just like watching the monitor and we're
like and then he won and we're all like
like everybody just we were just
everybody was just kind of floored
through the whole thing and yeah um
yeah and i was just thinking like about
how am i gonna what am i gonna do you
did a great job thank you
just in case you missed it the whole
thing started after chris rock made a
joke about the king richard starr's wife
jada pinkett smith live on air
the joke it was about jada's hairstyle
and because she suffers from alopecia a
hair loss condition she didn't think it
was funny neither did will and that's
when tension rose will got out of his
chair and smacked chris
and when amy resumed her hosting duties
following the incident she handled it
like a boss
oh gosh i mean i did my darndest i'll
just say that her approach playfully ask
the audience if she'd missed anything
important the trainwreck star previously
responded to the slap heard round the
globe writing on instagram that she was
triggered and traumatized adding that
she was still in shock and stunned and
sad before praising chris for handling
the situation like a pro
and all that echoes what her co-host
wanda sykes told ellen degeneres last
week i just felt so awful for my my
friend you know chris and uh it was
sickening it was absolutely i physically
felt ill and i'm still a little
traumatized by it me too will has since
issued a public apology to chris he also
resigned from the academy and is facing
a formal review where he faces potential
punishment including suspension
expulsion or other sanctions his hearing
which was originally scheduled for april
18th has been moved up to this friday
[Music]
you